[Music]  cuba has never seen this many people  ever and i've been in and out of cuba  for 40 years it's not i'm a republican  you're a democrat it's about i'm an  american and let's live like americans  we understand the mandates are ending  but this is about the rest of our  freedoms don't lock us down don't take  away what we have just let us be who we  are and who we work we got to save this  country  i don't want to leave the mess that  we've got going on for my babies or my  grandbabies or my great grandchildren  you know we're definitely moving away  from the mandates but most of us  american citizens are afraid especially  us type are afraid they're going to  bring them back for almost any reason  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  oh  [Music]  oh  [Music]  foreign